[Music]
on today's show we talked to a man who
has a family member who he loves but
who's also a racist bigot
we talked to a woman who's struggling
with boundaries with her grandmother and
we talked to a woman who is struggling
with attention issues and adhd and i
know a thing about that stay tuned
[Music]
what's up what's up
[Applause]
man it's so good to see you and hear you
and talk to you i can't see you or hear
you i'm not even talking to you but it's
so good that we're here together on the
dr john alone show we talk about mental
health relationships everything if you
want to be on the show give me a shout
one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one that's one eight
four four six nine three three two nine
one or go to johndaloni.com
ask a s
k
hey public service announcement
james you're the greatest producer ever
i feel like i bagged on you the last
show wasn't kind i don't know how these
things roll out in order but you're
great
thinks that sounded super sincere don't
be totally serious what if i had another
producer
what if there's some other shows in this
oh crap
so
here's the thing if you ever quit i'm
going to bring your house down not with
your family and i'll make sure y'all are
gone somewhere
whatever like whatever like i don't know
threshing wheat or whatever you all do
out there but
i won't burn your house down that
sounded mean but i'll be sad
there's so many other producers in the
building that aren't good and you're not
one of them
and
this show's hard
so thank you james
austin sitting in for jenna sitting in
for kelly
i'm glad to have you too
and i i'm jealous of your beard
i haven't shaved in like nine months and
this is all i've got it's embarrassing
it's ridiculous i'll go through puberty
one day it's gonna be awesome all right
let's go to mark in milwaukee what's up
brother mark
good morning how are you
oh i'm doing real well how are you doing
this morning real well too that's great
what's up man
well
excuse me so
uh the situation that i have is
i have a family member that i'm really
close with
and at the same time
we can't have a face to face without
like screaming matches
and
a lot of that has to do with the fact
that in my perspective
he is just
an indescribable bigot
and i can't let it go
hmm
that's hard man
so
how do you hold in
two two different hands how do you hold
one he's a great man
and then the other hand he's a bigot
that is is
so hard to be around i lose my character
and temper
that's why i'm calling
[Laughter]
gotcha
um i think we all especially with people
we love especially people we respect or
people that we are in some sort of
forced community with
we often
have a picture of them that we make up
and we impose it on them
and then their reality
bangs up against that picture
and we
we end up being the ones that go crazy
and so i want to challenge your original
picture
that this person in your life is a good
person
or a great person
or a person worthy of one second of your
time
so give me some things that make this
character traits that make this person a
great person
oh
very family oriented
extremely driven
loyal
loving
where he chooses to show it
it's very
he's giving
um
and i don't
part of it is you know obviously
the
the mental framework
and values that i was raised with
so
that's got a lot to do with where it's
coming from in terms of my my respect
for the guy
okay
so when the all the things you told me
there's a you can it has a fascinating
twist on them
driven loyal loving giving i wrote some
of these down
these are all traits that when you step
back and look at somebody
can point to a person of character
but it can also point to somebody who is
obsessed with control
oh
no comment
so when somebody uses love
as a weapon
it's this way and you get my love
it's not this way and i
done with you or i'm done with that
group of people or people who look like
that or act like that or love like
whatever the thing is
um i will give
generously obnoxiously
only
if you're in my good graces
and here's how you get in my good graces
i will be loyal to the ends of the earth
for only my tribe with which i describe
the you know do you see what i'm saying
oh
these things can be really
i mean this is how i this is how i i
look at the people around me
like are people i associate with are
they generous in giving the friends that
i have when we go to dinner the fight's
over who's paying not who's not paying
i remember back in college we almost
came to like fist fights over it i'm
paying this check for this table i'm
paying the check like it was a thing
and they're overly generous and i've got
friends who are overly loving
and overly like obnoxiously overly loyal
um
but it's a selfless type of love and
generosity
not one that helps control the world
around them right
so when you say uh like a major bigot
what does that mean
somehow
in every conversation racism gets thrown
in and it's just peppered in like it's
normal
and i just and and i i see white yeah
and i don't mean that in the racist way
i mean it's just i was gonna say who's
racist
just kidding
so yeah
i'm like whoa hit the brakes right here
right now i don't care what we're doing
i don't care where we are yeah i just i
just snap
and
this person is not gonna not be in my
life so i need
tools or tricks and see i want to press
on that why dial that button down why
have you why have you trapped yourself
number one
on behalf of humanity thank you for
standing up and saying that's not okay
i'm grateful for that voice we need more
voices like that okay thank you for that
um
why why have you locked yourself into i
will be in this person's life and this
person will be allowed into my life and
to my kid's life
well since i only called him to talk to
you about one topic
[Laughter]
i don't think you ever listen to the
show it's never about one topic well
right yeah no but we don't want to peel
back that cover too far right now okay
um
he's in my nuclear family okay and
my nuclear family
are not the only people i can count on
you know like
underscored count on sure but
it's pretty much you know i don't have a
huge friends circle
and
so it's
yeah
so let me let me
let's let's change this up a little bit
let's take racism out of here
all right
rage not anger but rage
kills us we know that yes and so let's
pretend that you have a family member
who's a great person
great guy
and every time you'll hang out he hands
you a cup of poison and says drink this
and when you do
you lose control of your body you lose a
couple of months off of your life
your blood pressure goes up
for the next 72 hours you can't think
clearly
you don't want to be around your other
loved ones
and then you begin to doubt your own
sanity and your own
convictions about things because of what
they cost you
and that's it
guy's great nice kind he just has you
drink a cup of poison every week
how long do you begin to value your
mental health and your physical health
and your spiritual health
over
that
and when i say value how long till you
just say i gotta go make some friends
that don't ask me to drink poison
well when you put it that way exactly
exactly
ultimately mark this is
the value proposition here is you
you don't value you enough
because you've created a world where
this has to be acceptable because i
don't have these these other things
and i want to tell you you can go get
those other things
you're worthy of
having boundaries where people aren't
disgusting
you're worthy of saying this is wrong
and this is where i draw this line
and you're also that means you're also
there's a reality to that
it's also worthy of going to
meet other guys meet other men and women
in your life that can come over that can
help you change the tire that can help
you fill in the blank fill in the blank
and
you're brave for making this call
there are millions of people going
through this right now whether it's
racism whether it's
any marginalized group covid
conversations whatever it is
people think i have to take this dose of
poison
otherwise the rest of my life falls
apart and i challenge that
wholeheartedly
what i hear often is people say oh my
gosh i didn't realize that by holding
the line on this boundary a
there was six other family members that
were like oh thank god now we can have
the conversation
or
i didn't realize how fun thanksgiving
could be i've hated it for 30 years
i didn't realize that it could be a
joyful holiday with just a couple of
knuckleheaded friends and strangers i
didn't even know we watched football and
played around and played dominant i
didn't realize that there was this much
laughter that could be had
that's what i hear often
but to ultimately answer your question
you can't control his behavior you can
only control the boundaries you put up
and i want you to know you're worthy of
strong boundaries
do other people in your family not call
bullcrap on this
um
no well okay not the people that
i interact with there are some
there are a few others that i think
probably would but i don't
i don't spend time with them
so
just physical location etc yeah
i want you to have a life of peace
brother
well you and me both thank you well so
but the next part of that is this you're
choosing right now to not have a life of
peace
and i know that sounds awful and i just
put you in a corner but that's the
choice
and i know also know we could probably
there's probably more complex more
complexity to this story you know if you
and i were hanging out and you could be
like and this and this and this
um
but i want you to have peace in your
life brother and right now you're
choosing this relationship and this
toxicity and you're choosing just to
drink poison just so you can keep this
connection
it's why people stay in
abusive marriages it's why people stay
in
keep going to the same christmas event
for 30 years in a row that's why people
stay in toxic jobs with bosses that beat
them up physically and spiritually
mentally
it's
[Music]
it's just look around in our country man
we're struggling
you're worthy of seeing i'm gonna be
around people who love not people who
hate
grateful for the call brother mark we'll
be right back from the doctor john
delune's show
[Music]
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you've got an expert in
a team who have your back listen if
you're about to buy a home and make a
big change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple h
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement mls id 1591
nmls consumeraccess.org equal housing
lender 1749 mallory lane suite 100
brentwood tennessee 37027 programs are
for select loan types only and are not
available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to megan
in canoxville tennessee what's up megan
hey how are you doing i'm good how are
you in knoxville y'all having fun
yeah i'm enjoying it very cool just a
few hours down the road from me what's
up how can i help well i have a question
related to family boundaries
specifically with my grandmother we just
had a call just like that this is gonna
be the boundary show all right so bring
it on what's up
okay so i am a senior at the university
of tennessee and when i started college
here
um i started calling my grandmother
and it became an everyday thing so i
have called her every day for the past
three years or more
and
you know we've gotten really close
because of it it's been good why'd you
start calling
we started getting closer that summer
before i left to college okay and then
it was kind of like positive
reinforcement like she was very happy to
be receiving these calls she would make
comments to the family
even comparing like
megan calls me every day or hannah never
called me but he became the golden again
yes you became that golden granddaughter
are you all in the same town we all live
in different cities
so she lives uh an hour away from me i'm
actually in that town right now okay to
the east yeah okay all right so
okay so you've been calling three every
day for three years yes most married
couples don't talk to each other that
often so well done all right so
so
moving forward
i have begun to realize that it is less
of a good you know
call and i'm enjoying it it's more of
this obligation and like a check box
like i'll plan my day like ah i gotta
call her at this time and i'll try to
plan it um just so i can make sure that
i said okay i did call her because i
have missed a couple of times and when i
have she will remember and she makes a
point of it like oh yeah i know you
didn't call me yesterday i was thinking
you were leaving me to the side or
something like that um
so wow that's such an exciting
what a great that's a great uh
power move it's a great guilt trip move
well done
so i'm i'm trying to wean off of it
because i'm applying to grad school is
that a good way to say it i mean
lean off of anxiety meds you wean off of
of calling graham
that's right yeah
and because i'm moving on to a different
phase of my life i'm applying to grad
school right now i have a new
relationship things are getting a little
bit busier
and it's not that i wouldn't have time
to call her every day you know if you if
you want to do something you can make
time for it but i don't know if i want
to
call her every day
and now i just feel like
she has this expectation and she's even
made comments about my sister who
doesn't call at all like well at least i
can count on you i know you'll call me
every day and i've kind of said you know
grandma sometimes
in the future i might not be able to and
she's like well i sure hope not i hope
that doesn't happen yeah i guess i'm
just thinking forward to the future you
know if i have a family and kids and
stuff am i gonna be able to call my
grandma every day
so i'm gonna free you from this you
don't have to feel guilty for not
calling your grandma every day
thank you
you're free be free
um i do think a
a
[Music]
um what's the right way to say it
some sort of boundary conversation would
be helpful
and
just know that any sort of boundary
conversation is going to come with
somebody who receives the boundary
conversation
really
banging their head up against that
boundary to see if it holds or not
and so if you say hey grandma we're
going to go down to once a week
i'm entering into a bonker season of my
life we're gonna get onto once a week
i'm gonna call you every sunday at
whatever
you provide yourself some clarity you
provide her some clarity and then
she's gonna get upset with you
she's gonna say well i don't know what i
did to hurt your feelings or i don't
know why you don't love me anymore
and that's where you this is gonna be so
hard but you as the grown-up have to
know
that that those kind of comments are not
about you those are that's about her
that's her choosing to try to exert
power over a young woman
um
in the in the counseling we call it the
one down position
instead of saying like like your dad
would might one-up position say you will
call me every day or i cut off your cell
phone cause i have bigger muscles than
you and bigger paychecks grandma in the
one down position goes
oh oh oh okay i i thought you loved me
but if you don't then um
okay
i hate to be a burden to you and i know
you're
i thought i was more important than your
boyfriend in in school but if i'm not
then that's great that's one down
position nonsense
see yeah um here's what really sucks
you can't control grandma
and you have to decide
am i gonna give her permission to speak
into every corner of my life
or is she going to be my grandmother
yeah i think
in the way my mind works i'm like okay
if i just plan this out perfectly no no
i can control her reaction but that's
not the case i can't no you can't the
best way you can do is be honest with
her treat her with dignity
with respect and if you set up a new
boundary you uphold you're into the
bargain so if you say i'm going to call
you every monday
at 8 a.m or whatever then build that
into your world
or if you say hey instead of calling i
want to start writing letters back and
forth that might be a good thing let's
start mailing each other letters i don't
get any mail
um
i'm running out of time where i can't do
these phone calls anymore or like you
said
i don't want to be on the phone all day
every day
um i'm working on talking on the phone
less but i do want to write letters to
you and i do love getting letters
because i i don't get them and i know
you're still in college you may not even
know what a letter is
um i like letters i actually just sent
out christmas cards i'm busy yeah
imagine if you got a christmas card
every week they're the best write each
other letters um but i'm trying to think
of maybe something like that
um but at the end of the day
this has become an area of esteem for
you and even though you don't like it it
kind of feels awesome when she talks
trash about her other grandkids
including your sister
and you're the best one it's kind of
awesome
and it kind of is lame too
and
it's time to let that kind of stuff go
it just no this is gonna hurt she's
gonna make you feel really guilty and
you're gonna feel guilty
because she doesn't really have many
people is the thing she doesn't that's a
choice that she's made or yeah
that's a choice that she's making on a
daily basis
and i hate that
does your mom call her or your dad
that's the thing that's where this is
it's my mom's mom my mom also has
since we moved here to tennessee for the
past i don't know 10 years she has
called her every day too
um
and then it kind of so she'll you it's
my mom and me that call her every day
those are the real two people that she
has
interacting with her on a regular basis
so in a weird way
yeah sorry mom you gotta call twice a
day you are basically your grandmother's
anxiety medication is that fair
it could be yeah um
yeah yeah that's not your job
your job is just like i've noticed
though
i've started to resent it there you go
and that ultimately that's where this
all ends up is instead of feeling guilty
about not calling you call and you call
and you call even i don't have time even
i don't want to even when i've got other
things that really need to get done
and then you land in resentment world
and then
like you start to not like your
grandmother because you make it her
fault that you can't not call
that's exactly what it is and sometimes
i even notice myself getting so annoyed
with her for nothing just because i'm
like oh yes because you're you're in
resentment remember this when you get
married because this will show up again
somewhere
are you gonna marry this person you're
with
i hope so oh gross are they cool
yeah
okay so there's gonna be things that
drive you crazy about them
and
you can feel guilty about saying
something and just choose to not say
anything like ah i really drives me
bonkers when you leave your shoes out or
can we all just agree to put our shoes
up
or i'm not gonna say anything i don't i
know they're working hard and i don't
i'll i'll feel guilty and then that
turns into resentment so just know
choose guilt over resentment every time
every time and choose dignity over all
of it right so being honest with your
grandmother letting her know what's up
choosing i'm not going to let her
make me feel bad for
first setting boundaries up in my life
i'm just going to make that choice and
just
you have to practice if she does get
upset about it let's eight let's back
that up 100 chance she will
okay a thousand percent chance she will
there is no way to manage the soft land
of this thing
she's gonna view it as a breakup and as
though she is in your way
and you have chosen grad school or some
some romantic interest or some dog or
some pet or that you're choosing these
things over her she's forced herself
into this binary it's me or everything
else which is not how any relationship
should be
but
you know who else does that children
young children
daddy don't go to work you should stay
here and play i gotta go to work well if
you loved me you'd say it on the play no
if i loved you i'd go get a job so that
you can eat you're right
and
such it is
in an ideal world your grandmother says
you're going to grad school that's
incredible you're not gonna have time to
talk to me every day let's talk once a
week
and i want to hear all about it and i
want to hear about this knuckleheaded
person you're in love with and all those
things that's an ideal perfect world
because that's a grandmother who's
interested in your success and your time
and trusts you to be a good steward of
your life
unfortunately we don't all get that
well i'll pray that that is the answer
but i don't think that's going to be
knowing my grandma 100 chance it won't
be
100 chance
but you're still worth it anyway is that
fair
yeah all right so
get your boundary lined up maybe go
ahead and tell your mom too this is
coming hey i'm gonna have a talk with
grandmother
um
and maybe write a letter too and mail it
so that she can know how exciting it is
to get a letter from you or i don't know
of something
but yeah there is no way to softland
this one just be honest be direct be
treat your grandmother with dignity and
then when she starts her
guilt-tripping
choose in your heart to say
that's her
processing her loneliness that's her
processing her grief
that's not mine to own she's a grown-up
she's a brilliant
strong
grandmother and she's making this choice
and maybe she will get some buddies she
can hang out with every day that'd be
even more awesome we'll be right back on
the dr john deland show
studies show that a lot of us dread
going to sleep at night maybe it's
because we're stressed because we didn't
finish everything during the day or
because our thoughts just won't stop
spinning or maybe our spouse snores so
loud or maybe our bed's 100 years old
and it's just not comfortable whatever
it is anticipating a bad night of sleep
sets us up to be miserable we get better
deeper rest when we look forward to
sleep and that's why it's so important
to create a sleep environment you love
jumping into for me the mattress is
critical but also pillows are key i hate
bad pillows but i got my dream cloud
mattress and they sent me these dream
cloud pillows and dude they are
incredible i can't wait to go to sleep
and you know what that helps me sleep
better now pillows aren't the only
accessory dream cloud makes to optimize
sleep they have luxury sheets they got
mattress protectors you name it and
today when you order a dream cloud
mattress you get
399 bucks of these incredible sleep
accessories and on top of that dr john
dolone's show listeners get an
additional 250 bucks off that's 649 in
savings not to mention some really good
sleep if you need better sleep check it
out at dreamcloudsleep.com
promo code deloney
all right let's take one more call let's
go to is it judea judea
joe jude judea
judea in oklahom oakland oklahoma in
oakland california
today i'm struggling with the old with
the old reading today sorry about that
how are you no worries i'm great how are
you excellent okay say it for me judea
judea
what's the origin of that name it's
beautiful it
thank you it's a um i'm not jewish but
it is a jewish name yes um you can find
it in the bible actually in the
christmas story
oh my gosh that was a great flex
where's your name from the bible
well done
i'm from scripture where are you from my
name is another term for toilet so
thanks for bringing that up judea much
appreciated
all right so what's up how can i help
i've had attention issues ever since i
can remember i have no idea what that's
like continue
oh man
okay so tell me about them
um so it was a really big stressor in my
in my family's life while growing up and
i feel like it still haunts me to this
day i'm now an adult with my dream job
and i'm struggling harder than ever to
keep up with my co-workers my current
therapist suggests i consider medication
or seeking a diagnosis for something
like adult adhd but i'm afraid it will
hurt me
i wanted to get a second opinion but
it's still something that i'm open to
considering gotcha okay
so when you say you've got attention
challenges
tell me what that means give me some
paint me a real picture of what that
looks like
that means i'll start on a task or i'll
start trying to listen to something
for example like when i was a kid in
class
um i'd maybe listen for about five
minutes and then
you're gone like something would yep
then i was gone something would be
difficult and my mind would just wander
i never really had the hyper activity
issue but i could sit there and look
like i was paying attention but it's
common with with
especially young young girls
they look like they are plugged in and
their minds are off to the races boys
yeah
and again i don't unnecessarily gender
but the data tells me boys will bang
their heads on things and
but girls can be equally
out too
um
have you over the course of your
lifetime or working with your counselor
have you identified some places where
your brain checks out for you
um i think a few mostly with academic
type pursuits so when i'm trying to
learn a new skill at work or something
that seems really complicated
it's as if i just say i'm out i can't do
this okay
what is your brain protecting you from
there
um
i'm a bit of a perfectionist i
definitely have a fear of failure i've
been working really hard on that where
does that come from who gave you that
i don't
i don't know um i wouldn't say my family
is super perfectionistic but my mom was
really hard on herself when she was
growing up to make sure that she got
good grades and i think
um
because she came from kind of a
difficult situation i think she was
always worried that um the same would
happen to me but if i wasn't able to pay
attention and do well in school then
um i wouldn't be able to get a good job
as an adult
how's your parents marriage growing up
fantastic they were always
um
they gave me a really good picture of
what a great marriage should be like
awesome so what about my dating life now
i look for people who
are kind like my dad is awesome awesome
what about um
what about brothers and sisters
i've got a younger brother and um he
tells me that he's had some attention
issues too
yeah
um so
you may have heard this show we think we
did a whole episode on this maybe a year
and a half ago or so
um gabor mate
m-a-t-e
wrote a book i think it's called
scattered
um i think that's it is that it
it's the what i consider the masterpiece
on
adhd
attention challenges
and so before i did anything i would
read that
book and when i say it's a masterpiece i
mean i sat there and wept through the
book and then i gave it to my wife
because i've i hadn't had my life peeled
back and i've read you name it the
i've read every book on adhd
just trying to figure out what where is
this
often okay it stems from
some sort of childhood chaos
okay or some sort of trying to connect
relationally go ahead
there was a period of time um right
after 9 11 i think in the years
following where um my mom was military
so
there was kind of this she was reserves
but there was kind of this understanding
that
there could be a time when mom would get
called to go
overseas
um and i think that might have had
something to do with it
i think maybe i would
um
like i was really little when they kind
of showed the attacks over television so
as a little kid that's
i mean as anyone at that time that's
really traumatic yeah and they've even
traced some of this back to maternal
stress like prenatally like when
somebody's pregnant so if your mom's in
the military and she's pregnant or she's
trying to figure out what she's gonna do
there's so much there
that um
all that to say is this often the
attention issues are a result of
your body trying to make sense of chaos
and i live with this every single day of
my life and so i'm telling i'm speaking
as to somebody you and i are in the same
club here okay
okay
um
i'm not opposed to medication
but when it comes to adhd man i want to
see somebody go to the ends of the earth
uh and so when it whenever
mainly because you get on a stimulant
track and there's no way off
the only move is to increase stimulants
for the rest of your life and the
downstream effects of some of those
things are
dramatic
and that's what i'm afraid of but it
also feels like that i've tried
everything else i feel like i've tried
changing my diet i've tried
just trying to white knuckle it through
times when i'm having a hard time paying
attention what brings you peace
i think knowing that
i'm capable of accomplishing the task at
hand
or knowing that i'm capable of taking
care of myself nope not that what brings
you peace
are you dating somebody now yeah do you
like them
yeah
like you like like them or just like
yeah
i i like liking quite a bit and um so
far it's been a very good relationship
how long
uh really only about eight months so
it's still kind of in the beginning
stages that's a thousand years in dating
world these days so good for you
so thank you
is there moments when y'all are together
and he's either holding you or you're
holding hands
and your feet are propped up
and your body goes
yeah
off and i'm yeah i'm not speaking this
into your life okay i hear this often
that
people who struggle with attention
issues with adhd with some sort of
i'll just say that with the 80d world
there can be a ping pong relationally
whether it's with multiple partners
multiple people multiple relationships
depth of relationship because there's
something about connection with somebody
else that makes everything go all right
we're okay
and it's a brain trying to solve for
connection desperately
and
some people solve for connection through
perfectionism i will score my way into
your heart
i will prove or earn my way
into
good relationship with you
the same exact thing just the other side
of the equation
is
i will burn this down so you will see me
drugs okay help am i is it ringing true
what i'm saying maybe not
yeah i'm definitely more of the i will
score my way into someone else's heart
type person gotcha and so if you're if
and i'm the same so i got two phds not
because i'm smart but because i was on
this continual treadmill to prove to the
world and to myself and to a few people
who didn't know i was trying to prove
myself to them
that i was capable and smart and blah
blah this was i mean now i'm celebrated
for it i got a job because of it but it
was purely
running tactics for me
and it was chasing chasing chasing and
it's when i was able to settle into an
actual relationship and by the way i was
married for 10 years before i figured
this out
really and then i had to practice what
does being in a relationship mean
not that my marriage is fine
i didn't know how to accept love i
didn't know how to accept peace i didn't
know how to accept calm i didn't know
what that was
and calm felt like quitting calm felt
like less than peace felt like well you
could be doing this
and so i was always spun up and so then
my body has to adjust and over toggle
and when things get complex it goes we
gone we out
that is exactly what i'm experiencing
and the loop never stops in fact the
loop gets tighter and tighter because my
guess is when you're up and you're on
you outwork everybody around you is that
fair
yeah when i'm really on i'm a hundred
percent unstoppable
yes yep and you get more done in those
times that everybody else does and so
when you fall off
um you're able to duct tape it together
get it across or just be like hey i need
an extension on this whatever until you
can find up the gumption to white
knuckle a thing and get it
done having a hard time getting back up
at the moment i think that's exactly
right because then you run into
something like i don't know like a
pandemic for a few years and your body
just goes hey how about this we're done
i'm out all right
yeah i started this job during the
pandemic and that was very difficult for
me yes yes because your body's trying to
deal with all the other threats too
yeah
so i'm gonna tell you the few things
that have worked in my life
and they are hard and they are annoying
okay
some of it is coming to truth and
and peace
with
the stories i was born into
meaning my mom and dad are two
extraordinary people
and i'm gonna do some things differently
with my kids
and i had to own that gap
i had to go back and figure out what is
my six-year-old self still trying to
solve
and it's almost always it's a worthiness
in relationship issue
yeah and so there's a season of anger
towards your parents or your brother and
sister or towards your teachers or
whatever there's a sing a season of
shame i can't believe i let that
whatever and then you hopefully get to a
season of peace which is dude there was
people just loving me the best way they
could with the tools they had it's
incredible i'm so grateful
i've came i've
come around to it um with the help of my
therapist and she's been absolutely
monumental in that awesome awesome
so then the next things were the things
that you mentioned diet exercise
community other people
often adhd folks
don't like to be in community other
people because they can't control the
interactions
and it's when i started making time to
be with friends even though it didn't
feel like productive time it was just be
when i made the switch in my head being
with my friends watching the fights for
four hours just sitting on chairs
running our mouths and talking crap
about nothing
that's productive time for my body is
when my body went all right cool let's
do that then i had to make peace with it
is that hard for you or do you like that
do you like more one-on-one interactions
or do you like
the life of the party
it depends
yeah yes when your body's exhausted when
it's not i love it we're basically the
same human except you're cooler than me
because your name's from the bible not
after a toilet it's awesome
um
sleep has become the main player in my
life
sleep sugar and screen time are the
three major players in my life
if i go a couple of days with no screens
i find my ability to plug in and be on
task to be
10x what it normally is
one quick question about that okay um
how do you do that when you're a
computer animator
you build in on time and off time okay
and unfortunately for a commuter com
computer animator
your downtime can't be the office
it has to be nature okay
okay and
that i you're downtown
today i'm into outdoor sports too yes
yes yes so your down time will be i've
got to always have a season of something
okay
and leaning into nature that's the other
one that get that the research keeps
coming back saying that people who go
out into nature it begins they call them
nature baths now that he it heals you
i'll spend time hiking in the woods not
even in an urban setting if i can
um i'll go on hike trails or walk trails
or whatever and i won't have a podcast
in i'm going to let my brain and body
rest because it's so spun up
and i'm going to double down triple drop
quadruple down on connection in
connection not for my value with
somebody else
but connection and learning to receive
the fact that i'm okay
i'm an all right guy
one of the great moments i had in
therapy
i walked out of a session and i felt a
hundred pounds lighter and the words
that came into my head were oh my gosh i
don't suck like i'm not a piece of crap
and i don't know where i got that from
my parents never told me that my
community never told me i just over time
had piled that one up
i'm that's exactly how i feel too
nobody's ever told me that i'm a piece
of crap but i've always thought that i
was and often that comes from oh you got
a 93 wow you only missed one huh if
you'd gotten one more right it would
have been 100.
or man you look so good in that dress if
you lost five pounds you would be a
supermodel
or
oh you're making 48 000 a year man
you gotta admit next time make sure you
negotiate better so you can get 55. and
it's not that somebody says you suck
they just move the carrot on you every
single time
yeah
is that fair
yeah that's very fair and what i want
you to to come to terms with come to
peace with is i'm all right i have value
that doesn't mean you don't live a
disciplined life adhd people have to
have a highly highly disciplined life
highly disciplined life if i don't
exercise the rest of my day falls apart
i know that i just know it and i hate it
it sucks it's my life though and i've
made peace with my life
and there are days when i have to get
this book done i just finished a
manuscript and got it sent in
the last two weeks
was some of the two of the hardest weeks
of my life it was a
absolute mind-numbing grind i was angry
i sent emails i probably shouldn't i
mean i was just angry all the time
and i have to i know now my family knows
i know my friends know my coworkers know
uh we're entering that season i let
people know i'm not gonna be fun to be
around for the next two weeks because i
gotta finish this thing and i gotta push
through
and
there is seasons when that that's just
part of life for us but it's not always
okay do you feel like you're gonna quit
get fired from your job
no but it's it's a fear that keeps me up
at night there you go
um now when i feel like i'm struggling
to learn yes that's anxiety
so you have permission to learn you have
permission to ask questions you have
permission to say i don't understand
this can you help me
and that is not an indicator that you're
dumb or that you don't have character
that means you need to learn different
ways and somehow for most of us that
stuff got jumbled up if you don't get
this grade on this test you're an idiot
and if you're an idiot i love you less
or if ida can't learn a thing as fast as
that guy on that computer over there
then he's going to get the raise i'm not
going to get the raise and then suddenly
i'm five years into the future where i'm
fired and homeless
that's exactly where my brain goes
that's anxiety
okay okay i'm gonna send you a free copy
of my book redefining anxiety okay it's
really short
and it clears it up really quick
and if you want how about this i'm gonna
send you two and i want you to take one
of your counselors and you all can read
it together okay that sounds fantastic
thank you so much you got so stay on the
line and jenna's gonna get you a copy of
it actually jenna's back austin left in
the middle of the show by the way the
people who are listening
um jen is back and i want you to read
that book it's real short you can read
it in like an afternoon
and then i want you to go oh
i believe i don't have any data that i
believe that adhd is on the anxiety
trend line it's a body's response to
chaos that turns into
every alarm bell we got ringing at every
time and most of our alarms ring because
we're disconnected from relationships
i wish it was more complex than that now
okay you solve for a relationship you
solve for peace you solve for the
anxiety
and you make peace with the fact that
your brain is supercharged
i consider adhd my superpower
let me put it this way we got into some
editorial disc like debates here in the
office i took a week off of work and
wrote 81 000 words i started over from
the very beginning of the book in five
days
wow that's a supercharged brain that's
my superpower
and my family left the state
they went to texas they're like we're
gonna let you do this on your own
because it's not gonna be a pretty sight
around here
and
so i made i've made peace with it my
family's made peace with it we got it
done it was brutal okay it was hard
and then jennifer who's the editor on
this book with me
oh gosh that she
when she dies she's just on an express
lane to the afterlife she'll just
they'll wave her in because of this one
season she's such a saint
um
but
i know that and so i'm going to treat
people kindly with dignity and i know
i'm gonna have seasons where i just have
to grind something out and it's awful
and it sucks i gotta do it i gotta do it
again i gotta do it again and i'm not
happy and i hate it it's driving me
crazy and there's gonna be days when
this is my superpower and i can outwork
everybody
all of that starts with loving yourself
in relationship
thank you so so much for the call just
so you know your bravery just speaking
this out loud is gonna help a whole
whole bunch of people i'm grateful for
you
thank you cool stay on the line and
we'll get your information we'll get you
the book sent out all right thank you so
so much for your call
man
james you couldn't have picked a better
song this was also
i got this man i had a ucd haul the
other day
minor threats like all of the records
all of them on one cd was so great uh
who else did we get um
the drop drop kick murphy's an old bad
brains record and alicia keys record oh
my gosh she's so good
and taylor swift i got taylor swift
record it's so good
alicia keys man i love this song song
this is for our friend
judea
her name's from the bible and the song
is called so is yours by the way you've
you read the book of john yes
there's a few johns those are four of
them i think
i know just trying to make a joke there
goes james getting all jesus on me
[Laughter]
yes it's from the bible too hey
kelly's here
she's coming to look over jenna's
soldier um janice
never mind all right the song is called
girl on fire by alicia keys and it goes
like this
she's just a girl and she's on fire
hotter than a fantasy lonely like a
highway she's living in a world and it's
on fire
feeling the catastrophe but she knows
she can fly away
oh
she got both feet on the ground and
she's burning it down
she got her head in the clouds and she's
not backing down this girl is on fire
oh my gosh i hope alicia if you're
listening to this which for sure you are
call me let's do it
this girl is on fire
she's walking on fire
this girl's on fire i don't even know
what this means but it sounds incredible
we're all on fire
it's awesome see you soon on the dr john
dolan show